etats unis et france ont convenu de
rétablir la confiance entre leurs deux
pays et comment ça va se passer on va
voir cela avec notre correspondant à new
york thomas bonnet
[Musique]
thomas bonjour alors après cet entretien
qu'elle est la tonalité des relations
entre paris et washington
mais on peut dire que l'heure est
désormais à l'apaisement après cet
entretien téléphonique entre le
président emmanuel macron et le
président joe biden leur est désormais
un autre entretien qui va se dérouler
ici à new york il aura lieu demain entre
jean yves le drian et son homologue
américain anthony blinken une étape vers
un retour à la normale des relations
entre les deux pays alors les deux
hommes jean yves le drian et anthony
blinken en réalité déjà échangé quelques
mots ce mercredi dont au siège à des
nations unies ici à new york alors même
que justement lundi dernier lors d'une
conférence de presse jean yves le drian
avait dit qu'il ne prévoyait pas de
rencontrer son homologue américain mais
qu'il allait certainement le croiser
dans les couloirs du siège de l'onu et
bien si cette rencontre va pouvoir avoir
lieu c'est bien parce qu'il ya eu donc
cet échange entre joe biden emmanuel
macron un entretien qui a duré 30
minutes et qui a donc conduit vous
l'avais dit au retour de l'ambassadeur
de france aux états unis dès la semaine
prochaine à washington alors la suite de
cet entretien on a eu donc ce communiqué
conjoint posté par les deux présidences
un communiqué au ton très diplomate pour
arrondir les angles en quelque sorte et
ce qui est intéressant c'est en réalité
de voir comment cela a été présenté par
les différentes parties engagées d'abord
il ya joe biden qui a posté sur ces
réseaux sociaux une photo prise
justement au moment de cet entretien
téléphonique avec emmanuel macron et
envoie le locataire de la maison blanche
tout sourire évidemment c'est aussi une
façon pour lui de communiquer sur le
fait que la relation avec l'allié
français s'améliore et que les choses se
sont bien déroulées c'est un récit qu'a
d'ailleurs été repris tel quel par la
porte parole de la maison blanche ce
mercredi je propose de l'écouter
le ton de la conversation était amicale
le président espère que c'est un pas
vers le retour à la normale d'une
relation longue importantes et durables
que les états unis ont avec la france la
conversation a duré environ 30 minutes
comme nous l'avons noté dans le
compte-rendu elle a été longue mais au
cours de la conversation le président a
réaffirmé l'importance stratégique de
l'engagement français et européens dans
la région indo pacifique engagement sur
lequel nous sommes impatients de
continuer à travailler en collaboration
avec eux
alors de son côté aucune publication sur
les réseaux sociaux du président de la
république française emmanuel macron
mais qui a finalement décidé donc de
clore ce chapitre tendue du moins à
court terme car maintenant ce qui va
être intéressant évidemment c'est de
voir s'il y a des traces de cette crise
diplomatique car les mots quand même été
très dures de la part de la diplomatie
française la réaction de paris dans ce
dossier a d'ailleurs beaucoup surpris le
président américain c'est ce qu'on peut
lire dans différents articles de la
presse américaine et si le position le
positionnement des modèles macron avait
été plutôt unanimement saluée par la
classe politique française la sortie de
crise elle provoque plus de réactions
négatives que ce soit à droite comme à
gauche beaucoup estiment que cette crise
diplomatique a finalement accouché d'une
souris tout ça pour ça finalement c'est
un peu ce qu'on peut entendre chez un
certain nombre de politiques en france
alors ce jeudi c'est bien plus qu'une
rencontre qui va se jouer ici à new york
entre jean yves le drian et anthony
blinken parce que ce sera aussi un
révélateur de l'état réel des relations
entre la france et les états unis après
six jours d'une crise que l'on considère
comme la plus grave depuis le non à la
guerre en irak en 2003
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas abonnés en direct de
new york